well corey maybe we can use this
particular platform right now to put to
bed
a question that gets asked to me every
time i do a q a
every time billy and i do a convention
together or separately
anytime i'm online people in the street
have asked me maybe from now on if
someone asks me i can say you can refer
to the corey olsen episode of the french
bunion where we finally answer the
question that was asked to us here by
some movie guy named josh
why didn't they use the eagles to fly
tomorrow now billy and i have our own
answers yeah but let's get let's give it
the expert answer
okay so there are
several different answers to this
one and the simplest and most obvious
answer to this is that that is a crappy
story who wants to read that story who
wants to watch that yeah there's no
drama right that's a that's a terrible
story right so of course that's not
going to be how it's going to happen i
mean and by the way you can do that to
any story that's ever been written right
you can always say like you're going to
remove any drama from any story by
saying well like if like some like all
you need is to introduce some kind of
deus ex machina yeah there's always a
way to short it's a short circuit of
goals and it's never a good idea yeah so
that's like one
simple answer right but as far as like
from within the world of middle earth
there are good reasons for this too and
that is that the eagles they're not a
taxi service they're not even just
animals
like you can't you can't like
you can't like hire a winged uber like
it's not how it works
the eagles are not only free agents
they're they're kind of a big deal yeah
kind of a big deal
yeah i mean they're highly intelligent
and they're they're not even
beasts like they're not even animals
they're not even just birds they are
also like the balrog and gao and and
gandalf and sauron they are like angelic
beings manifested in a body the body
they choose is body of giant eagle
rather than body of uh you know old guy
with beard and really long eyebrows like
gandalf
harmonize with me and hold me back all
through the night you're shining bright
i'm your boy's the baby you're my pearl